hey guys uh
i know i look like the emperor from uh
star wars right now but i'm uh very high
in the air
back from london headed to uh new york
city
i decided to do a uh video uh mainly
because
i've caught up with my email and i don't
like wasting time
and i figured you know it's 2012 it's
early boy my eyebrows look insane
um it's early in the year and i figured
uh it's almost february
uh i'm clearly not excited about uh
football
uh small's coming up and i figured you
know what why don't i rant make a little
garyvaynerchuk.com video
see if i can bring any value just read a
bunch of emails
i get a lot of emails from entrepreneurs
who you know are looking for advice
trying to figure out how to make it you
know and i think about a lot of things
especially on these flights when i get a
lot done
and i'm just thinking thinking about my
life thinking about what i want to
accomplish and
figured you know hit record see what
comes out of this see if there's any
value for anybody
um i think people underestimate dna a
lot
you know i think that uh a lot of my
success happens because
i was born with it i also think that uh
people underestimate
how insanely obvious it is for some
people and how
murky it is for others what i mean by
that is it's
always been obvious to me it's always
been obvious what
caused success what i needed to do
you know every time i watch content
through the internet or on television
i watched oprah the other night lizzie
was watching and i was working
she was interviewing george lucas and he
was saying the same [ __ ] same [ __ ] i
always say
same [ __ ] i hear from everybody who wins
you know i think the
fear of losing trumps the excitement of
victory for so many people
i think people are so scared you know
it's kind of like hitting on girls you
know
i uh i get it right because i kind of
was more scared of hitting on girls than
i was
in winning in business i was much more
fearless
in executing business models than i was
about
going up to a girl and getting shot down
nobody wants the
the rejection nobody wants to lose
so i understand the philosophy i
understand that string of dna
that doesn't want to make you lose um
but i'm i'm so desperate to figure out
how to convince people that there is no
loss
in going for it that yeah you might get
made fun of
and you might have it in your own mind
but trying to figure out how to make
people drop that fear
of going and building a business for
themselves in 2012
trying to figure out how to make a video
or give a talk
or send a tweet or
write a book just something that makes
people understand that
executing the way it always is following
the school business model
which is such worship is going to lead
you to a place where you're not going to
win
um or that is a place where you're going
to win
meaning some people are meant to be b
and c players
some of you are not meant to you know go
out and win
you know i think this whole like if you
try it will come to you
there's such worship i'm worried that
people are confused
that you know effort or the secret or
hustle is enough because it's not
it's part of the equation but talent and
skills and the ability to work hard and
having
thick skin do you know how obnoxiously
thick my skin is
when it comes to business i don't give a
[ __ ] what anybody says about
me or thinks of me or thinks what i'm
doing when it comes to business
because i trust my intuition one good
trillion percent
i know that i'm built to win when it
comes to business i always win
i'm gonna win and people that don't
understand
my style or don't think that i'm doing
the right thing or think that
vaynermedia is a dumb idea because it's
you know it's uh it's client services
they just don't know me they don't
understand
what i'm going to do they don't
understand that it's early
people just don't understand how early
it is i'm 36 i'm a kid
you know [ __ ] but i want to be 25 like
aj [ __ ] yeah
but i'm 36 in six years i'll be 42. do
you know how much i'm gonna do in the
next six years
i'm just worried that people don't have
patience i worry that people don't tap
into their strengths
my strengths is that i tell stories my
strength is that i understand people
my strength is that i understand how to
build organizations
to succeed my strength is that i
understand that people
is what are what
the foundation of any business is my
strength is that i give a crap
yeah i care about myself more but i
actually care about you as well
my strength is that i'm a communicator
that i'm showman
that i know how to brand that i'm
willing to work ridiculously hard
that i have intuition on where things
are going that i work
tirelessly to listen to people that i
think know where things are going
that i engage that i genuinely care
that i'm willing to sit here right now
and make this video hoping that one
[ __ ]
one [ __ ] says oh [ __ ] yeah like [ __ ]
it
[ __ ] mom [ __ ] professor tom
[ __ ] what the intuition of other people
is i'm gonna listen to mine
the establishment the blueprint [ __ ] all
that
just gonna listen to myself listen to
yourself always wins
do i have angst sure i'm calling out
myself every day
for the last six or seven years telling
everybody i'm gonna buy the jets
i gotta roll billy's deep 36 getting
older
worrying about like the time but still
betting on patience betting on i've been
right
betting that i get better every year
betting that the 2006 version of me that
was so cocky
that rolled with massive bravado is a
punk compared to the 2012 version of me
because that's the truth
you keep getting better i'm betting on
that i continue to listen
continue to stay humble while still
being obnoxiously confident
i'm betting that the world's changing
and i'm paying attention
understanding that you got to play that
money ball game
which means data is the game but putting
eq on top of that
matters betting that all the good that
i'm trying to give everybody
comes back to me that somebody that i
affected opens a door for me
betting that the people i'm networking
with now on a daily basis
from 9 00 pm to 2 in the morning open up
doors
open up opportunities open up my mind
betting that the work i put in
operationally on vaynermedia is going to
pay dividends
is it sexy no am i turning down things
like tv
yes am am i less famous a little more
quiet
a little more off the grid absolutely am
i happy that i'm executed
and that i'm making [ __ ] happen and i'm
building a business one good trillion
percent
betting on a lot of things my friends
depending on a lot of things but most of
all betting on my community
community is the last great asset when
you play all these chess moves out
it's gonna be the only thing left the
people that give a [ __ ] about you
and the people that you give a [ __ ]
about and they're gonna open up the
opportunities
the doors the business opportunities the
life opportunities
and i'll always bet on that i believe in
that until the end
and so i sit here and give this seven
minute 37 second rant
to you because i think real and
authentic and honest
matters i think i'm good enough to win
and i think you're good enough to win at
your level
am i gonna win at the ultimate biggest
guy of all time
gates sucks buffett probably not
i'm more charismatic and loving and more
interesting than those characters
think so do i have enough to get me to a
billy
i think so but is that 40 billion no
are you good enough to get to 100 000
400 000
i think so just sat here and read 100
emails from people
that were making 40 50k 30k read crush
it read thank you economy got inspired
by me
but i was a spark i was the one that had
that
insane thing that i have in me that made
them say hmm
you know things that make you go hmm 80s
sorry but then they had it in them
and so when i make this video what's
coming from my heart right now is
maybe you're watching this and saying
hmm maybe i need to hedge
you know if you work from 80 pm to 4 in
the morning
will your dreams come true no you might
not be good enough
you might have not picked the right
product but are we living in a world in
2012 that's so much better than your
parents
and grandparents and great grandparents
generation because [ __ ] like me can
make videos
when i'm 30 000 [ __ ] feet in the air
yes
and because of that and because of those
opportunities
because we're networked in a way we've
never seen before and because sending an
email to 100 people and one will answer
and give you a shot matters because of
that opportunity
because of 2012 i beg you
i beg you to take a shot roll up on that
hot chick in a bar
and ask her out roll up on that good
looking dude and ask him for coffee
roll up on your business idea and make
it happen because
being 50 60 70 80
90 and having regrets that you didn't
swing the bat
is the worst of them all our at-bat is
in front of us
take a swing